how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Marvel has just made some major moves
moves that are somewhat bittersweet but
overall will make the future of Marvel
and the future of the MCU very very
exciting not too long ago it was
announced that Kevin Feige who is the
president of Marvel Studios was
announced as the chief creative officer
of Marvel Entertainment overall this
means that Kevin Feige now oversees all
of Marvel Entertainment content creation
including publishing film TV and
animation and yesterday it has been
reported that the TV arm of Marvel
Entertainment is being folded into the
Marvel Studios group and this was from
The Hollywood Reporter this means that
moving forward the comics the TV shows
and the movies from Marvel are all going
to be overseen by Kevin Feige himself
and this is extremely good news it's
good news because some of those
characters that you love so much from
the Netflix series and other TV shows
could be making a comeback characters
likely Inhumans Jessica Jones daredevil
iron fist and Ghost Rider all of these
characters are now under the direction
of Kevin Feige and although it is just
speculation for now nothing has been
confirmed it seems like some of these
characters especially Ghost Rider could
be making their way to the MCU and this
could be via a television series or a
Disney Plus series so I'll talk about
this new report and talk about the fact
that the Ghost Rider television series
for Hulu was scheduled to come out but
when Kevin Feige was announced CC o
chief creative officer / Marvel
Entertainment that show was pulled from
Hulu real quick if you're new don't
forget to subscribe when notifications
turned on like the video and leave a
comment down below so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 so The Hollywood Reporter has
reported that the TV arm of Marvel
Entertainment has officially began the
transition of heading under the
direction of Kevin Feige and Marvel
Studios all current development of the
Hulu slate of animated comedies and the
live action drama hell strong will
remain on course however nothing else
will come from Jeff Lewis was the
executive / the live-action TV series
now according to The Hollywood Reporter
unfortunately a couple of dozen people
are going to be laid off
however the extremely interesting part
is that most of Jeff Lewis team
including Marvel TV senior VP of current
programming and production Karim shriek
will join Marvel Studios and stay
onboard it's also interesting that Ghost
Rider was suddenly cancelled as well
right around the time that Kevin Feige
was announced chief creative officer of
Marvel Entertainment and a very
important thing to note here is that
Marvel TV is not going to end The
Hollywood Reporter made it very clear
that this is not the end of Marvel TV it
is simply under the direction of Kevin
Feige and Marvel Studios now which is a
very very good thing because for a very
long time there has been a wall between
Marvel TV and the MCU and now that wall
is knocked down because Kevin Feige is
now in charge of both so we've had shows
before like jessica jones that offenders
the Inhumans daredevil Luke Cage all of
which were supposed to exist in the same
universe as the MCU but don't and Kevin
Feige has recently came out and
confirmed that those shows do not exist
in the MCU agents of shield is kind of
the exception to this rule because
obviously some of the Avengers have
appeared on the show but anything that
has happened in agents of shield has
never affected the MCU but as I stated
now everything is under the direction of
Kevin Feige and has the backing of
Marvel Studios this means that any of
these shows could be rebooted despite
their lack of success fans really did
enjoy the Netflix shows and obviously
most of them have ended or are going to
end because of Disney Plus but
eventually Marvel will have complete
ability and freedom to turn any of these
shows into a Disney Plus show so again
although nothing is confirmed there is a
chance that these shows could be making
a comeback and the ghostwriter
cancellation was a pretty big shock to
most people but it does seem like
everything leads to Ghost Rider getting
its own Disney Plus show
Gabriel Lunas Ghost Rider has now been
cancelled Kevin Feige is in charge of
all of Marvel's Disney Plus shows as
well as all of Marvel TV and there are
some reports from inside sources such as
cosmic book news.com Daniel RPK and
Lords of the long box that Ghost Rider
will be getting its own series on Disney
Plus nothing has been confirmed yet by
Marvel Studios but the Marvel TV
department has been moved under Marvel
Studios it's all under the direction of
Kevin Feige now and most of the TV team
has stuck with Marvel which means that
Marvel TV is definitely going to
continue under the direction of Kevin
Feige
and now that that wall is broken between
the MCU and the TV shows that opens it
up for some characters to return and be
a part of the MCU as well as new
characters to enter in Disney Plus shows
as well so be on the lookout for some
familiar faces to return to Marvel TV
whether that's via Disney Plus or some
other platform but Marvel Entertainment
has officially begun their transition
and things are getting very exciting out
of all of the characters from the TV
shows of which one would you like to see
enter the MCU via Disney Plus or other
means let me know who you would pick in
the comments down below and also don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
with notifications turned on so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 you can also click the
link in the description down below for a
chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet and
don't forget to use code cosmic at G
fuel comm for 30% off G fuel as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
you